.
GREAT JOB AS USUAL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: DOWN IN GEORGIA,
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE STACEY
ABRAMS IS IN MORE HOT WATER
TONIGHT, WE ARE NOW LEARNING
THAT MARJORIE CASEY, THE
FOUNDATION SHE WORKED ON, BOARD
MEMBERS SAID STACEY ABRAMS
SERVES ON INCREASED THEIR
ANTI-POLICE FUNDING SHORTLY
AFTER SHE JOINED THE BOARD AND
WITH HER APPROVAL, THAT'S
DESPITE HER CAMPAIGN SAYING SHE
DISAGREES WITH THE FOUNDATION ON
THESE ISSUES.
HERE WITH REACTION AS REPUBLICAN
SENATE CANDIDATE IN GEORGIA,
HERSCHEL WALKER, WHO HAD A HUGE
WON IN HIS PRIMARY.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU BACK, I'M
SUPPORTING HER CANDIDACY.
YOU ARE A FRIEND AND I THINK IT
BE A GREAT SENATOR FROM THE
GREAT STATE OF GEORGIA.
WHERE DO THINGS STAND THERE
TONIGHT?
>> THINGS STAND WELL RIGHT NOW.
THE BIG RACE IS ON IN YOUR 100%
CORRECT, IT'S GOING TO BE A
TOUGH RACE.
STACEY ABRAMS, YOU SEE WHAT
SHE'S DONE IN GEORGIA, SINCE ONE
OF -- THE STATE IS ONE OF THE
WORST PLACE TO LIVE IN THE GUY
RUNNING MAYBE BELIEVES THE SAME
THING BECAUSE HE DID SAY AND SHE
SAID THAT THEY'RE RUNNING ON THE
SAME TICKET, MEANING THAT THEY
BELIEVE IN THE SAME THING.
THAT MEANS THAT THEY LIKE THESE
HIGH GAS PRICES.
I DON'T.
THEY LIKE THE MILK AND EGGS TO
BE AS HIGH AS THEY ARE.
I DON'T, AND WE OUGHT TO GET
THIS BACK TOGETHER.
ALL OF THESE STATES THAT ARE RAN
BY DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE CRIME
THAT IS GOING OUTRAGEOUS, AND
EVEN RIGHT NOW YOU LOOK AT THE
BORDER.
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE
BORDER?
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, NOW THEY
DON'T SEEM TO BE CARING ABOUT.
RIGHT NOW THEY'VE GOTTEN ONTO
SOMETHING ALSO WE GOT TO GET
THESE THINGS SOLVED, WE GOT TO
GET PEOPLE IN OFFICE THAT WANT
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS RATHER THAN
GET A SOUND BITE.
>> Sean: RECORD GAS PRICES,
RECORD HIGH INFLATION.
WE NOW HAVE THE LARGEST CARAVAN
HEADING OUR WAY SINCE THESE
CARAVANS STARTED.
RIGHT NOW THAT'S HAPPENING.
THE DISASTER IN AFGHANISTAN,
EVERY SINGLE DAY PEOPLE PAYING
MORE FOR EVERY ITEM THEY BUY,
EVERY TIME YOU FILL UP YOUR GAS
TANK, AMERICANS ARE FEELING THE
PAIN.
QUESTION IS, OKAY, LET'S ASSUME
THE REPUBLICANS CAN TAKE THE
HOUSE.
LET'S ASSUME PEOPLE LIKE YOU CAN
WIN AND BUD CAN WIN AND WE CAN
PICK OFF A STATE LIKE
NEW HAMPSHIRE, NEVADA, ARIZONA.
ASSUMING ALL THAT'S TRUE, J.D.
VANCE, MINUTE OZ -- IF THAT
HAPPENS, WHAT
WILL REPUBLICANS BE ABLE TO DO
WITH JOE BIDEN AS PRESIDENT?
>> ONE THING IS GOT TO DO IS GET
THIS COUNTRY BACK TOGETHER AND
TRY TO GET THE GAS PRICES DOWN.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MOST
PEOPLE -- WHEN I'M GOING AROUND
TALKING TO GEORGIANS, THEY ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THE GAS PRICE.
IF PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT WHEN WE
LOSE OUR ENERGY, THAT'S A
NATIONAL SECURITY PROBLEM.
NO ONE SEEMS TO BE TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
WE'VE GOT TO GET THESE GAS
PRICES DOWN, WITH GOT TO
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT OUR MEN AND
WOMEN IN BLUE, WITH GOT TO GET
THIS COUNTRY BACK TOGETHER AND
HOW IN THE WORLD CAN WE FORGET
ABOUT BABY FORMULA CONNECT TALK
ABOUT -- THEY FORGOT ABOUT BABY
FORMULA, WE GOT TO GET THOSE
THINGS TOGETHER.
SO WHEN I GET INTO OFFICE AND I
WANT EVERYONE TO GO TO
TeamHerschel.com, PUT HERSCHEL
WALKER IN THAT SEAT BECAUSE THE
BIG RACE IS ON NOW.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, W